سيروفيكان كابوسا يقلق منامهم
وشبحا مرعبا لا يأمنون ضرباته
مهمته بمئات الصواريخ والقذائف
التي دمرت اوكرانيا وجعلت
الوحيد الموجود في قائمة اكثر
مائة شخص تثق بهم موسكو. يوم
الرفيعة في الجيش الروسي مثل
وسام النجمة الحمراء ووسام
لاستراتيجية الارض المحروقة في
المعارك. فقلد العديد من الاوسمة
والهجمة العسكرية بنفسه وبكل
جرأة وشراسة. اتهمته منظمات
القوات الاوكرانية وعلى دعم
الغرب. ذاع صيته اكثر خلال
ضحايا الحرب السورية من
المواطنين ابرياء دون العسكريين.
في الحرب الروسية الشيشانية
الثانية وحرب سوريا. واه على
في مقاطعة سيبيريا الجليدية عام
ستة وستين. شارك في حرب
الحرب الاوكرانية لصالح الدب
الروسي كما فعل في حرب القرم ام
بتلك الكلمات اسكت كل الافواه
التي تتهمه بالخيانة. ولكن
السؤال الان لك عزيزي المشاهد.
هل ترى ان الجنرال الجحيم سينهي
يفوت الاوان. من الضروري
الالتزام باوامر الرئيس الروسي.
بيومين، وهذا ما اجبر على
التراجع عنها في اللحظة الاخيرة.
صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال ان كان
يخطط لاعتقال كبار قادة الجيش
الامن الفيدرالي الروسي بمخططات
قائد فاجنر قبل موعد تنفيذها
المسلح ضد موسكو. اما بالنسبة
لعلاقة الجنرال الروسي فقد نشرت
الدفاع الروسية اعتقال. اليكم
المصدر وهذه المرة المصدر هي
زيلنسكي وحلفاؤه ولم يدم احتفال
كياف طويلا. فقد نفت وزارة
والغرب بالتخلص منه? وهل تم
اعتقاله الصيد في الماء العكر.
الغرب يحاول ضرب عصفورين بحجر
واحد. فبعد ذلك انتشرت انباء عن
لن ادع اعداء روسيا يشربون
القهوة في الصباح لانه لن ياتي
تحتفل بالخبر السعيد. من هو
سيرجي سورفيكان ليحتفل الاوكران
قائلا احضروا فورا. ليعلن الجيش
الروسي ان والملقب بجنرال الجحيم
القرم التابعة لروسيا. الكرملين
يعتبر الواقعة تعبيرا عن الطبيعة
استدعاء جنرال الجحيم. ثمانية
اشهر على عملية الدب الروسي في
رأس الشيطان. لتنفي وزارة الدفاع
الروسية وتصبح الاخبار
مهمة تدمير اوكرانيا. وهل حقا
تحالف مع فاجنر وانقلب ضد بوتين
اقحام اسمه في تمرد فاغنر ضد
بوتين. لعلهم منه ويستريحون من
كابوس الغرب وشبح مرعب للجيش
الاوكراني وكل اعداء روسيا. ويد
الاوكران لا يعرفون صباحهم من
مسائهم. قام بتطويق القوات
سيافرو دونيتسيك. فور تعيينه
قائدا للعمل في اوكرانيا استهل
الاوكرانية في مدينتي جورسكي
وزولوتي والسيطرة على مدينتين من
عند سماعهم نبأ اعتقال ولكن هل
تم اعتقال جنرال الجحيم فعلا ام
الفين وواحد وعشرين. ومنها بدأ
عملياته في اوكرانيا. ففي اقليم
على زيلينسكي والجيش الاوكراني.
ترقى لرتبة الجنرال في اغسطس عام
المعارضين لتفكيك الاتحاد
السوفيتي. في ذلك الوقت قضى
ومن هنا اصبح مقربا اكثر من
الرئيس الروسي. خروج الشبح الى
الضوء. بدأ سوروفيكان بالظهور في
المشهد العسكري بشكل رسمي بين
للعمليات في الجيش الروسي. وفي
عام الفين وثلاثة عشر عين قائدا
حقوقية بارتكاب جرائم حرب في
سوريا. واطلقت عليه قواته لقب
فترتين في السجن بتهمة بيع اسلحة
وقيادة طابور خامس ضد المتظاهرين
عامي الفين وخمسة والفين
وثمانية. عندما تم تعيينه مديرا
ليظهر بنفسه موجها رسالة الى
قائد فاجنر محذرا من ان ما يفعله
تعيينه قالت عنه مواقع روسية ان
بامكانه كسر البيوقراطية
القاسية. اما بالنسبة لاوكرانيا
فيوم تعيينه يعتبر يوما اسودا
اهم المدن الاوكرانية. هل علمت
الان لماذا احتفل الاوكرانيون
للمنطقة العسكرية الشرقية. وفي
عام الفين واربعة عشر شارك في
العمليات العسكرية الروسية في
سوريا عام الفين وخمسة عشر.
والتي قام فيها بضرب ضباط من
هيئة الاركان العامة ليقوده
الجنرال هارماجيدور. او جنرال
الزمان. لقسوته وكثرة استخدامه
الاستحقاق للوطن الدرجة الاولى
والثانية. كان الشخص العسكري
الروس وشارك في الحرب الاهلية في
طاجكستان في التسعينات. كما شارك
يكن للجنرال الروسي اي علم
بمخططات او حتى اي تعاطف معه
الروسي ومن ضمنهم وزير الدفاع
سيرجي شويغو ليعلم حينها جهاز
الروسي لم يكن على علم بمخططات
قائد فاجنر وانه لا يؤيد التمرد
في اوكرانيا. وشهد شاهد من اهلها
ليؤكد الكرملين ان الجنرال
عشر من عمره. كان له دور كبير
احداث الانقلاب على ميخائيل جورج
افغانستان في ثمانينيات القرن
الماضي ولم يكن قد اكمل الثمانية
ان الغرب سيكون له رأي اخر?
القاب مرعبة وتاريخ من الدموية.
دومباص حاصر القوات الاوكرانية
في جوريسكي. وسيطر على مدينة
العسكرية في الجيش والوصول الى
بوتين مباشرة. يعتبر الغرب
الحرب اوكرانيا بشبه جزيرة القرم
التي انتصر فيها الدب الروسي على
التسريبات الاعلامية تزف
للاوكرانيين خبر اعتقال سيرجي
ملتهب عاشته اوكرانيا ليخرج
جنرال الجحيم بعد ذلك ويعلق قائل
فاجنر. هو انه اتهام صريح لجنرال
الجحيم روسي بالخيانة العظمى.
موسكو. احتفلت كياف بالخبر. ولكن
الحقيقة كانت عكس ما تمناه
حقيقة جنرال الجحيم. تم التأكد
من ولاء وكشف الخدعة الغرب فلم
او مصدر في وزارة الدفاع الروسية
للجزيرة نفى الانباء عن اعتقال
الجنرال سيرجي سوروفيكين نائب
قائد العملية العسكرية الروسية
سورفيكان لاتهامه بالاشتراك في
تمرد فاجنر ضد بوتين. قيادة كييف
عليهم صباح. يا الهي اي مصيبة
وقعت عليك يا اوكرانيا. رائحة
قناة والتي تتعارض مع سياسة
روسيا. تابع فيها فقد نفى وزير
للتوقف. العدو ينتظر اي توتر في
الوضع السياسي الداخلي. لا يجوز
القاب لاحد شياطين الحرب.
المقاتل المتمرس سيرجي سيرفيكان.
صاحب الخمسة والخمسين عاما.
تاريخ من الدموية والقسوة. ولد
اخر رؤساء الاتحاد السوفيتي عام
واحد وتسعين. وكان من اشد
يصب في مصلحة اعداء روسيا قائلا
ادعو قيادات ومقاتلي شركة فاغنر
اللعب لصالح العدو في هذه
الاوقات الصعبة على البلاد. قبل
جنرال يوم والجنرال هار ماجدون.
والجنرال القادم من الجحيم. كلها
وكأن الغرب قد احترف رياضة الصيد
في الماء العكر. ولا يريد تفويت
الشهيرة. لن ادع اعداء روسيا
يشربون القهوة في الصباح. لانه
لن يأتي عليهم صباح. تصلب وجهه
وتجمدت ملامحه. واصبح لا يعرف
القيامة. واطلق عليه الغرب لقب
الجنرال القادم من الجحيم. هو
الرحمة. احتفل الاوكرانيون بعد
سماعهم نبأ اعتقاله. وحاول الغرب
المتضاربة. من هو الجنرال سيرجي
سوريفيكان الذي اوكل اليه بوتين
وتم اعتقاله لتعرف اجابة كل تلك
الاسئلة. تابع الفيديو للنهاية.
الارهابية الاوكرانية حسب
تصريحه. ومسئول اوكراني بتلك
وكل شيء غير شرعي يجب تدميره.
بوتين يستشيط غضبا ويأمر قادته
قد دخل حلبة الحرب الاوكرانية
ليكلفه بوتين بنفسه بقيادة
وتلك الوداعة التي يطيع بها
الاوامر تنقلب ملتهب على اعداء
روسيا. جعل ليل كياف نهارا
بصواريخه الصماء. وقال مقولته
الفرصة الذهبية للتخلص من كابوسه
بوتن. فبعد التمرد الذي قاده
اعلام غربية ان الجنرال كان على
علم مسبق بما يخطط له قائد
اعتقال سورافيكان بتهمة الخيانة
العظمى وايداعه سجن ليفورتوفو في
الاراضي الاوكرانية. انفجار شديد
يحدث في جسر كيارتش بشبه جزيرة
الزاوية يعلن التحدي علنا قائلا.
تفجير جسر كيارتش هو مجرد بداية.
العمليات الخاصة على الاراضي
الاوكرانية. يبدأ سورفيكان اولى
عملياته بامطار كييف بمئة صاروخ
روسي كحفل استقبال. نعم. صباح
زعيم قوات فاجنر. ضد موسكو والذي
مات قبل ان يولد. نشرت وسائل
موسكو الباطشة في حربها الكبرى.
يأمره بوتين فيرد. سمعا وطاعة.
بشع في صورة انسان. اطلقت عليه
قواته لقب جنرال او جنرال يوم
ان ستلد لنا اخبارا اخرى لتؤكد
او تنفي.